el centro del círculo es o encuentra las
longitudes de
c de c d y f
efe muy bien aquí vamos a utilizar
varios teorema de pitágoras porque
tenemos tres triángulos rectángulos sin
embargo todavía no conocemos toda la
información para aplicar pitágoras en
cada uno de ellos por ejemplo en este
triángulo de acá si queremos encontrar
la longitud de cde usando el teorema de
pitágoras necesitamos la longitud de la
hipotenusa que todavía no tenemos nada
más tenemos la longitud de este lado que
es 15 de manera similar aquí no
conocemos la longitud de la hipotenusa
pero si este lado que mide raíz de 141
su número horrible entonces todavía no
podemos aplicar pitágoras pero acá si
acá tenemos la longitud de dos lados
este que es 24 y este que es 7 de esta
forma si le llamamos x a oa x
podemos aplicar el teorema de pitágoras
en este triángulo y obtener que x
x al cuadrado es igual es igual a 7 al
cuadrado 7 al cuadrado más 24 al
cuadrado más 24 elevado al cuadrado
vamos a realizar las operaciones nos
queda que x al cuadrado es igual a 49 49
más 24 al cuadrado es está difícil dejar
de hacerlo por acá 24 por 24 ok 4x4 es
16 y llevamos una 4 x 2 es 8 y una que
llevamos 9 2 por 4 es 8 2 por dos es
cuatro
y sumamos aquí queda 6 9 y 8 17 y
llevamos 11 y 45 queda 576 entonces
equis cuadrada es 49 más 576 576 de modo
que x al cuadrado es igual a a ver
cuánto da la suma pues es lo mismo que
sumar 50 y restar 1 verdad sumar 49 es
lo mismo que sumar 50 y restar 1 576 más
50 es 626 pero restamos 1 y queda 625
625 ok y a lo mejor te sepas que el
número al cuadrado es 625 es 25 entonces
nos queda x igual a 25 pero si no lo
sabías lo puedes verificar elevas 25 al
cuadrado y queda 625 ok entonces x vale
625 perdón x vale 25 y entonces estos 25
y por lo tanto la longitud de a a
es igual a 25 vamos con los otros dos
triángulos parece que todavía no tenemos
la información pero ya sabemos que a es
igual a 25 es decir que el radio del
círculo es 25 y notemos que 11 y 12 los
dos son radios del círculo entonces este
mide 25 y éste de acá también mide 25 y
ahora sí vamos a terminar aplicando el
teorema de pitágoras un par de veces más
voy a hacerlo en color verde para este
triángulo de acá a efe déjame llamarle a
saleh entonces aplicando el teorema de
pitágoras aquí tenemos que al cuadrado a
al cuadrado más raíz de 141 al cuadrado
lo voy a poner así raíz de 141 elevado
al cuadrado es igual a 25 al cuadrado 25
al cuadrado ok entonces al cuadrado más
121 141
es igual a 25 al cuadrado que dijimos
que 625 625 restando 141 de ambos lados
al cuadrado es igual a a ver cuánto
queda la resta cinco menos uno es 42
menos cuatro termina en 8
y hay que prestarle uno a este 162 es 4
a cuadrado es igual a 484 que el número
al cuadrado da 484 sin creo que éste
está un poco más difícil voy a tener que
dividir este número en factores 484 es 2
x 242 242 es 2 x 121 está muy bien y 121
es 11 x 11 de esta forma tenemos lo
siguiente que 484 484 es igual a 2 por 2
por 11 por 11 es decir 2 al cuadrado por
11 al cuadrado que es igual a 2 por 11
elevado al cuadrado que es igual a 22 22
al cuadrado entonces a cuadrada es 22 al
cuadrado
de modo que a
a es igual a 22 qué bueno que quedó un
número más bonito que raíz de 141 ok
entonces am a es igual a 22 y eso lo que
nos dice es que el segmento o efe
tiene longitud 22 y finalmente hay que
aplicar el teorema de pitágoras en este
triángulo de acá lo voy a hacer en color
azul a esta longitud que desconocemos le
voy a llamar b y una vez más tenemos que
ver cuadrada más 15 al cuadrado
be cuadrada + 15 al cuadrado es igual a
25 al cuadrado 25 al cuadrado be
cuadrada más 15 al cuadrado cuánto es 15
al cuadrado haber lo hago por acá 15 por
15 me parece que esos 225 pero mejor lo
checamos 5 por 5 es 25 5 y 15 por 15 y 2
que llevamos 71 por 15 es 15 y sumamos
sumamos 52 y llevamos una dos hojas 225
de cuadrada más 225 nos queda igual a
625 por lo tanto b cuadrada es igual a
400 restando 225 de ambos lados a 400 y
400 tiene una raíz fácil verdad es 20
entonces b es igual a 20 éste mide 20
éste mide 20 y entonces las longitudes
las longitudes de hd
efe son 25 20 y 22